In this application,
you saw the infrastructure for
how Geo-fences work in Android.
You saw how easy it is to set up
Geo-fences, and how you can use
an intent service to handle
the transitions between Geo-fences.
In this case,
we hard coded several locations but
there's no reason why you couldn't put
your Geo-fence data into the cloud and
have your phone dynamically update
the number of Geo-fences that it tracks.
So for example, if you wanted
to have a virtual treasure hunt
with locations that change every day,
you could do so and
have your app update them
whenever it launches.
There's just so
much that you can do with Geo-fencing.
Particularly, now,
that the users carry these powerful
mobile devices with them all the time.
We scratched the surface
of what you can do.
But in doing so,
we've built a powerful scaffolding
that you can use in your future apps.